hi I'm Lauren good I'm a senior writer
at Wired and today we're going to be
talking about today we're gonna be
talking about user experience design
specifically we're gonna be sleepy sorry
can we do that again notifications their
incessant I get something like 80
notifications per day and some people
get as many as four times more
notifications than they'd like to
according to one study that we looked at
so unless you've turned off
notifications entirely or you've gone
the dumb phone route you might be
feeling frustrated too so I've spent the
past couple weeks trying to get to the
bottom of how we got here with
notifications and what notifications are
doing to our stress levels and our
productivity and how they might be fixed
I talked with a psychological researcher
if you get a notification it has a
visceral physiological response in your
body a professor who studies a
distraction I see an opportunity here
for ironically developing technology to
help people deal with technology and a
designer who developed some of the
earliest smartphone notifications every
piece of Technology every every design
that you create you're trying to solve a
problem and sometimes you introduce
unintended consequences
so how did we get here well in some ways
notifications are nothing new especially
when it comes to communication there's
some sort of call to action landlines
rang and mailboxes had flags and
answering machines blinked but the
internet changed everything and suddenly
that mailbox notification was much more
immediate you've got mail
yeah good mail and by the early 2000s
that blinking light on your answering
machine had become the blinking light of
your BlackBerry since then those blinks
have become buzzes and pings and banners
and badges those little red dots that
light up your smartphone screen and let
you know just how much stuff you're
missing out on no notifications stretch
you out Larry Rosen is a research
psychologist who studies the effect of
Technology on us
if you get a notification it has a
visceral physiological response in your
body it releases chemicals the most
commonly studied chemical is cortisol
but other chemicals in the in the
anxiety realm are also studied according
to Rosen those chemicals cause all kinds
of physical reactions sweaty palms
queasiness and the fear of missing out
on little bits and pieces of that that's
normal that's kind of our daytime
routine but if it's over and over and
over and over again you're constantly
getting notifications beeps buzzes
vibrations all of those are contributing
to ongoing chemical stress maybe you've
experienced this but this notification
overload even leads us to imagine that
notifications are happening when they're
not like the phantom buzzes just ten
years ago we felt a little tingling down
where our pocket is we would have
reached down with our fingernails and
scratched the itch
now nobody scratches that itch everybody
believes that it's an incoming message a
notification a vibration oh my god
somebody's trying to reach me in fact
most young people check their phones
every 15 minutes or more frequently than
that once again for fear of missing out
half the time interruptions are from
oneself so their self interruptions
psychologist Gloria Marc studies
multitasking and digital interruptions
she says that interruptions don't just
cause us stress they have a profound
impact on our overall productivity and
while her team study
different kinds of interruptions like
instant messages and phone calls
notifications are a form of that when
people are interrupted right there
they're not just interrupted and go
right back back to the task at hand nope
we get sidetracked really sidetracked
it actually takes them about 25 and a
half minutes to get back to the original
task and what happens in between is they
work on two other tasks this creates a
cognitive burden on people and that's
associated with stress and it's also
negatively associated with productivity
so an interruption is an interruption
but with an in-person interruption there
are still some social guidelines in
place with digital notifications they
can happen anywhere all the time the
thing is notifications were not
originally designed to be this way
they weren't even called notifications
maybe if we talked about them we talked
about alerts to better understand smart
phone notifications I went to see Matias
Duarte Duarte leaves the material design
team at Google years ago he was the
director of Design at androids
predecessor danger where he worked on
the coolest phone of the early 2000s the
hip-hop better known as the sidekick now
earlier phones of course had very
limited communications phone like this
the only kind of message you would get
would be SMS or missed call or a
voicemail for this we wanted to receive
all sorts of different types of
notifications or messages because we
wanted you to download apps and so we
had to come up with a system for
notifying you about them because we
couldn't just have a whole bunch of
individual indicator lights you know
you'd run out of room right but they
didn't think people would want
notifications that often news here is
something we thought people might want
to hear about on a six hour early basis
right email well yeah
email once an hour and there were some
stuff we were certain folks would never
want a notification of like games Duarte
and the danger team took what was then
desktop chatting and tried to take it to
mobile interestingly they were trying to
solve around a couple problems one the
standard use case of having a blinking
light you can only fit so many blinking
lights on a phone
and to the sounds almost everybody now
complains about vibration
oh gosh does those drive me nuts right
at the time vibration was the solution
because the the world that people lived
in was a world where having a little
time a ding-ding-ding all the time that
was normal right and it was starting to
get to be too much the world changes and
what people think is appropriate or
healthy or expected changes too and we
have to keep engaging with that in order
to be helpful to people for better or
worse they also open up notifications to
third-party developers who to this day
are still trying to grab whatever sliver
of our attention that they can this is
left work day with some mixed feelings
about how notifications work all
technology is a double-edged sword and
so I feel very happy that I was able to
help with many many other people in
solving some of the communication
problems and making people more
connected and I also feel responsible
about some of the the challenges that
we've created for some people and some
of the unintended consequences may be
mostly I feel guilty I feel more bad
than good that's not true I don't feel
more bad than good we were doing a lot
of good things you know for good purpose
but we also need to be wide eyed and
acknowledged that you know there were
consequences also however unintended
they were and in so much as I can so
there you go there's your interruption
so how do we fix this for starters tech
companies say they're trying to make
notifications more manageable so
starting with iOS 12 an iPhone for
example notifications were grouped
together the same way they have been on
Android for years and you can reply to
some notifications like message
notifications directly from the
notification itself on Android you can
put your phone into do not disturb mode
or you can shush your phone put it
facedown and not get bothered by
notifications both iOS and Android now
have built-in dashboards that tell you
how many minutes per day you're spending
on your phone
what apps are using the most and yes how
many notifications you're getting per
day it's not going to fix the problem
but it might let you know that you have
a problem because that's how I knew that
I had the problem of getting something
like 80 notifications and of course you
can always go into settings and just
manually go through each app and figure
out which one you want to turn off
notifications for but honestly it's a
little bit painstaking and I kind of
wish that these super smart smart phones
that we carry in our pockets were smart
enough just to do a little bit more
around notifications like if I could do
this hey Siri turn off my notifications
before I go into my next meeting you
want to cancel your meeting called
Lauren dentist at 8:00 a.m. tomorrow is
that right
no I want you to turn off notifications
before my next meeting
okay I won't delete it and even though
Google's assistant tends to be a little
bit smarter this isn't much better hey
Google turn off all notifications before
my next meeting to open Android
notification settings tap notification
settings below and the cycle continues
so that's not great
in the future these tech companies may
use things like artificial intelligence
to better determine which notifications
are worthy enough to actually interrupt
us but they're just not there yet
critics say these notifications are
something that tech companies really
still aren't doing enough to address
instead they're just perpetuating the
whole attention economy it is a business
and their business is to get your
attention to get your eyeballs focused
on their site their app whatever it is
and in order to do that they have to do
several things one they have to get you
there first and often the way they get
you there first is by either a
notification or even if you shut off the
notifications a really slick looking
icon on their home screen there are
usually about 12 to 15 icons on a
smartphone they're beckoning at you
their job is to stand out and others say
we might need more technology to help us
with our problem with technology so if
one of the things that we're exploring
through this video is who should carry
the burden
fixing notifications so I can't help but
wonder if more of the burden should be
on tech companies and app makers or if
it should be on us the humans who are
text messaging each other all the time
in sending each other all kinds of
messages and alerts I don't think anyone
is to blame without any entity is to
blame but I see an opportunity here for
ironically developing technology to help
people deal with technology people can
can learn and be empowered to be able to
resist notifications and I think that's
where technology can can help people one
example of that is an app called day
wise which patches your notifications
together and sends them to you at set
times throughout the day so you're not
getting flooded with notifications I've
been using day wise I have it set to
send notifications three times per day
and I find it helpful like for example
if I were to check my 3:00 p.m. batch I
can see that I have nearly 800 Twitter
alerts not really but it feels that way
thanks a lot Twitter thing with day wise
though is that it only works on Android
and some of the permissions it requires
in order to work well or a little
invasive also this is just one app okay
so how do we really fix this some
technologists believe that wearables
could be the solution the idea being if
you have something on your wrist that
gives you a little bit of haptic
feedback you're not being distracted all
day long by this others believe that
heads-up displays can be the solution so
that you're getting messages in front of
your eyeballs although then you're
getting messages in front of your
eyeballs so who knows others believe
that sound design could be the answer so
here's what I want in addition to
thinking hard about the ways in which
humans are interacting with each other
and messaging each other all the time
and using all of these applications
I want these super smart tech companies
the ones that tell us these products and
make these platforms to also think hard
about delivering a thoughtful
notification experience use some of
those smarts and those brilliant AI
solutions to make notifications a lot
more manageable so that it's not just a
great software experience but it's also
good for our human we're
[Music]